Begin by talking about the book in
Florence,
which resulted from my two and a half
year program of research into the
training programs of all of the
different influence professions to see
what they do to get us to say yes.
I was surprised by one thing that I
encountered in all of these programs.
There were only six universal
principles.
Now there were hundreds,
maybe thousands of individual tactics,
but only six universal principles of
influence that seemed to capture the
great majority of what all of these
individuals were doing.
Reciprocity,
the desire to have all of us to give
back to someone who has given to us.
So if an individual gives us something,
a free sample,
for example,
we feel obligated to at least listen to
what they have to say at the,
at the supermarket,
for example,
that little lady with the cubes of
cheese and meat.
After you've eaten one of those,
it's very hard to just give her back the
toothpick.
Yeah.
You feel like you've abs obligated to
buy.
Reciprocity is one another is scarcity.
The desire to have those things you can
have less of.
So things that are scarce,
rare,
dwindling in availability.
So one of the things that,
uh,
many,
organizations will do is to inform us of
how a rare,
how uncommon their features are.
Uh,
another principle is commitment and
consistency.
The desire to be consistent with what
we've already said or done,
uh,
to,
to be congruent with our internal values
and,
and what we've said that we're going to
do.
So for example,
one study showed that if you call people
on the phone,
uh,
registered voters and ask them if they
will vote in the upcoming election,
they of course say yes and they now vote
significantly more often than if they
didn't receive that phone call.
Getting them to commit to that sort of
thing.
Another principle is consensus or what
we call social proof.
The idea that people want to follow the
lead of similar others,
people just like them.
We've done a study,
for example,
in hotels,
I don't know how much you travel,
but,
uh,
when I do in 70% of the hotels where I
stay,
there's a little laminated card asking
me to reuse my towels.
And linen.
We put different kinds of cards in rooms
to see what we could say on the car.
That would most increased the likelihood
that people would say yes.
What hotels typically say is do this for
the environment,
do this for future generations or
cooperate with us toward this common
cause.
We added a different sign based on the
principle of consensus that people want
to do what everybody else is doing.
It said the majority of guests who stay
at our hotel do recycle their towels at
least once.
That was absolutely true and it
increased compliance by 28% the
interesting thing is that was a
completely costless message and it's
never ever been used in any hotel in any
city that I've visited and the reason is
those managers don't know what the
research says.
One of the hopes in these books that
I've been publishing on the influence
process is to allow people outside of
the academic community,
the non researchers who in any
meaningful way have paid for this
research with their tax dollars to learn
what we found out about them with their
money.
They're entitled to know what we found
out about them with their money.
And so that's one of the purposes of the
book,
to be sure that we present this
information to the wider public besides
just the academic community in which the
work was done.
We undertook the publication of the yes
book as a way to change the perception
of persuasion as just an art.
Something that people are born with,
with some sort of Predator natural gift
for saying the right thing at exactly
the right time.
And there are artisans of the persuasion
process,
no question about it,
but it turns out persuasion is also a
science for over a half a century.
Now researchers in various kinds of
situations,
mostly psychologists,
communication professionals,
sometimes marketing,
uh,
professors in business schools have been
studying how you can say something in
one particular way that will
significantly increase the likelihood of
ascent to that thing and have been
checking their theories and their
hypotheses in scientific experiments
that allow us lessons that we can
provide to the larger community beyond
the scientific establishment of how you
can be more effective and how you can be
confident that you will be more
effective because it's grounded in true
science,
not just hunches and speculations of
people who,
uh,
want to talk to you about this process.
What I'm going to claim about the
principles that we talk about is that
they are universals of influence.
There are so central to the human
condition,
so fundamental to the way we work as
citizens of modern society,
that you will be able to use them
successfully or they can be used
successfully in all kinds of domains
with your friends,
with your neighbors,
with your coworkers,
with your boss,
even with that most resistant of all
audiences,
your children.
I'll guarantee that these principles are
so fundamental there,
so psychologically central that they
strum strings that are inside all of us
and that we try to resonate with in
order to behave correctly.
The difference between influence and
manipulation is an important and
profound one like dynamite.
These principles,
these tactics,
these lessons can be used for good or
ill.
The difference is the extent to which
they are employed
by someone who's taking a detective's
approach to the influence process rather
than a smuggler's approach.
A smuggler imports one or another of
these principles into a situation where
it doesn't naturally resist exist.
For example,
excuse me.
Let's say for example that we use the
principle of authority.
We can move people in our direction by
claiming to be an expert on some topic
that we're talking about.
And if they believe us,
it's very human for them to want to take
the shortcut route and follow what a
legitimately constituted expert says.
If we're not in authority,
we have exploited this process to bring
people in and we've manipulated them and
their interests and their outcomes.
Uh,
there's a short term success,
uh,
consequence of that.
People do say yes to us,
there's a longterm disastrous
consequences is that they don't want to
continue to deal with us if we fool them
into yes.
On the other hand,
if we're a detective of influence and we
go into a situation where we recognize
that we are genuinely in authority,
all we have to do is raise that to the
surface and significantly increase the
likelihood that people will be counseled
correctly into a good choice to make.
So for example,
we did a study with a hospital,
um,
uh,
physical therapists.
We just asked them to put on the wall of
the physical therapy lab.
All of their credentials,
all of their diplomas,
all of their awards and compliance with
their,
um,
with their exercise regimens went up 30%
immediately.
Not because it's not so surprising that
people want to follow the lead of
legitimate authority.
The interesting thing is that that below
the surface,
that genuine authority,
all it had to be,
all there had to be done was that
somebody like a detective Saul was there
and brought it to the surface.
So it would be available to people,
uh,
to base their decisions on.
Yeah,
no,
it's a,
it's a great question because it gets
back to the,
uh,
to the question of ethics again,
which is
if somebody is trying to influence me
and I've read my book,
um,
and I know that they're trying,
I should not be automatically resistant
to that.
I should only be resistant to the person
who's trying to manipulate me into yes,
by claiming to be an authority when he
or she isn't.
I do want to follow the person who's the
genuine authority.
For example,
I do want to follow the person who gives
me true information that what they are
rec recommending is consistent with an
existing commitment that I've already
made a priority that I have in my life.
Or I do want to,
uh,
be,
vulnerable to the appeals of someone who
tells me about a genuinely unique or
dwindling availability that has value to
me.
All of those things are,
are influenced dimensions along which I
want to move,
except when they're counterfeited.
So the key is if I've read about
influence and I know about it,
I should no longer be simply alert to
the fact that somebody is trying to
influence me.
It's a more subtle differentiation.
I need to be alert to the person who's
trying to influence me with genuine
information about the uh,
the factors that steer me correctly
versus somebody who's trying to
fabricate that information
for yes,
there are such features.
So for example,
um,
one of the principles of influence we
talk about is liking people prefer to
say yes to those they know and like,
and one of the factors that causes us to
like somebody else is how similar we
feel to that person.
So the individual who on a youtube video
comes across as,
as every person as just like the
audience to whom he or she is speaking,
we'll get that liking,
we'll get the rapport,
we'll get the focus of attention and
will make the information more likely to
be considered.
The same thing goes with the authority
principle that we've talked about.
The extent to which you can appear more
authoritative,
more credible,
more knowledgeable,
and you can do that.
For example,
by doing something as simple as speaking
slightly more
then normal,
we assign greater credibility and
knowledge and confidence to people who
speak slightly more rapidly than normal.
If you speak too quickly,
then you look like,
uh,
some,
salesperson who's trying to pull the
wool over their eyes,
but slightly more rapidly than normal.
You get a sense this person knows what
he or she is talking about and you're
more willing to take that information
in.
I'm not sure if you were your,
your viewers would recall,
but there is a public service
announcement that was run back in the
70s and eighties called the [inaudible]
iron eyes,
cody spot.
That is the,
is reputed to be the single most
effective public service announcement
about the environment that has ever been
sent to the American public.
It showed a picture of a very stately
buckskin clad,
a native American paddling his canoe up
a river that,
that,
uh,
floated with various kinds of pollution.
He came to the side of the river.
The bank was covered with pollution.
He came to the side of a road also
littered.
A car went by and through garbage out
the window.
It's fast food bag at his feet.
It's splattered.
The camera panned up and you saw a tear
running down his face.
Very powerful message,
don't litter.
We have evidence that that message not
only maybe less than optimal,
it may actually be damaging to the goals
of the creators of that ad because the
sub text message was everybody's
littering.
Everybody does this and that is a more
primitive message then this native
American actor doesn't want you to
later.
Right,
and we've done studies to show that if
somebody watches while someone else
litters into an already littered
environment,
just as what happened in that iron eyes,
cody spot,
it significantly increases the
likelihood that observers will later
there.
The thing you can do to decrease
littering is to have someone litter into
a pristine environment that causes
people to say,
wait a minute,
you are a northern breaker.
I don't want to be like you.
And they see,
they see significantly suppress their
tendency to litter as a consequence of
seeing somebody later into a cleaning.